and I'll actually have your own story
right that you're bring to the table and
I find insanely passi go ahead and tell
everybody they're not gonna believe you
yeah so I weighed 322 pounds about five
years ago so you know weighing that and
then coming to be a trainer on The
Biggest Loser five years later it's just
insane but you know I'm a single mom I
just beat Stage two thyroid cancer this
year yeah so hurdle and hurdle and yeah
yeah and I feel like everything's kind
of brought me to this point and to share
that experience and what I've gone
through with the contestants I've had to
relive that and I get what they're going
through so for me it's such a fulfilling
thing yeah I feel like I get it like
those tears you're crying I've cried
those tears like that Burpo you're
complaining about I've also gotta pee oh
my god I hear it's like the devil's work
it's it's it's it's sure that I mean
it's completely different but the
analogy of it is everybody was ask me
about the voice what I love about the
voice it's the same thing I've actually
been in their shoes and when you're
actually trying to coach someone that
you've been in their shoes you feel like
you have some kind of connection that
maybe everybody can't have you know
that's probably coming from you that
means a lot you know I'm saying that
you've been able to shed all that weight
and like - yes surely she really put her
heart all over that gym floor every
moment that she was there she she just
she's the real deal she really delivered
every single day and we're just so lucky
to have her oh my god you had a heart
attack right I did it's been almost
three years now I had a heart attack
when I was living in New York City and
dropped not only did I have a heart
attack but I went into cardiac arrest so
I felt like a Biggest Loser contestant
during my recovery because I went from
doing Crossfit and being able to work
out so hard all the time to not being
able to walk around a city block without
feeling winded had to change everything
about the way that I ate and everything
about the way that I worked out and as I
was going through my rehab I was just
like wow this is what it feels like to
start back at square
and that's what I've gone through gosh
it's once again though it means so much
more I know that sucks having had to go
through it's the worst gift you can ever
get but you know what make something out
of me yeah you can relate to them
they're like people you can relate and
say have had to work from the ground up
to like that it means something
different when you say that I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this